Papapa Papapa we're back with part two
of Detroit become human I got about 5
million supportive comments telling me
you didn't save the fish you heartless
bastard how could you I didn't see it I
didn't see the fish are you happy now I
went back just to save the fish like it
matters if I oh my god that is so cute
you're welcome fish now the whole game
is completely different yeah
alright let's go back to where we were
ah and here we are for real though
really appreciate all the supportive
comments I'm thrilled to finally do a
full let's play it's been so long there
has to be something about that coin by
the way it's the second time we see it I
wonder if we got Connor killed you know
like I messed up in the first episode
will we not play as him again because I
know he's like one of the main
characters no androids allowed savage
mode let's go everybody what's up big
yes
find lieutenant Anderson no problem look
around using the right stick scan faces
good thing I could read that and thanks
to the thing who said that huh who said
that what are you hmm
looking at you I bet you are unemployed
what a loser
Bobby drink huh who's this guy huh bet
you watch naked ladies there's many
great more jokes coming up guys we got a
one-hour episode of nothing but this
Lieutenant Hank Anderson
well you look nothing like introduce Alf
lieutenant Anderson my name is Connor
I'm the Android sent my cyber life I
looked for you at the station but nobody
knew where you were they said you were
probably having a drink in your bar I
was lucky to find you at the fifth bar
wow so lucky what do you want you were
assigned a case early this evening my
homicide involving a cyber life Android
in accordance with procedure the company
has allocated a specialized model to
assist investigators well I don't need
any assistance especially not from a
plastic [ __ ] like you
Wow just be a good little robot and get
the [ __ ] out of here
let's threaten lieutenant Anderson I
must inform you that I intend to file a
report on your behavior
persist I'm sorry but I must insist my
instructions stipulate that I have to
accompany you know where you can stick
your instructions know where and his
plastic butthole let's buy him another
drink you know what I'll buy you one for
the road
what do you say bartender the same again
please really see that Jim wonders the
technology he'd really like that I
wonder if that affects the game at all
I'm making weird choices did you say
homicide
I worked look we're best friends now
just keep providing this man with
alcohol and everything will be fine
got it
that race against the machine that must
be a reference you wait here wait he's
driving what a mad leg no way I'm coming
with you
listen you really have to stop pissing
me off if you want to make it to the
rest of the night in one piece selecting
priority conflicting orders follow
lieutenant Anderson all right I'm sure
he's gonna love that I'm not confirming
anything
except that you're an [ __ ] androids
are not permitted beyond this point it's
with me
you know talk you don't touch anything
and just stay out of my way got it got
it
even Hank we're starting to think you
weren't gonna show
yeah that was the plan to lose a soul
found me
very funny just tell me what happened
nice Ireland to speech you can write
haven't paid us back for a few months so
he thought he'd throw pies
Wow I wonder how much a rent you pay for
a place like this wonderful it's either
boomer from Leopard gamers he was inside
most of the time they hardly ever saw
staties yes calling everybody out in the
middle of the night coulda waited till
morning
I'd say he's being there for a good
three weeks we'll know more when the
coroner gets here there's a kitchen
knife over here probably the murder
weapon any sign of a break-in
nope the landlord said the front door
was locked from the inside all the
windows were boarded up the killer must
have got out of the back way what do we
know about his Android not much
the neighbors confirm he had one but it
wasn't here when we arrived I gotta get
some hey make yourself at home yeah I'll
be outside if you need me
you know what I don't want to judge for
anything but I bet he deserved it 30
year-old boomer I bet he was home all
day playing video games drinking energy
trailers perfect it's way too neat no
human rights all right let's look for
more evidence Chris we need 10 just
written in the victim's blood but I
would say so we're taking samples for
analysis
an alliance no fingerprints Android
involvement question mark
and you're gonna catch a lake my dog
Jesus what the hell are you do yeah I
can check samples in real time really
good I'm sorry I should have it okay
just don't put any more evidence in your
mouth you got it
god I love their dynamic all right we're
collecting that at its Carlos 19 days
almost three weeks more blood
oh it says examining the base seems
their friend Carlos like good party
excuse me Carlos I want full analysis on
the narcotics oh sorry Carlos you look
really gross I don't not so close red
eyes is that the name of the drug
wonder why the drug is so popular I
guess everyone is unemployed but then
how do they afford the drug conspiracy
solved by Felix everybody you're welcome
oh man you must be checking off the line
yeah there's definitely better jokes
coming keep watching please I don't know
how I feel about this I've gotta be
bored
all right the victim fell here and then
this is where you got nothing there's
nothing the victim was stabbed that's it
that's better and they came from the
kitchen so it was a woman joking I can't
I can't do this I'm just gonna say
something silly bad forget to edit it
out yeah seems like the killer really
had it in for
now I don't mean to sound like a
psychopath consider it done lieutenant
but if I was gonna murder something I
will probably stab them a lot of times
too right it's not like a gun where you
just you just shoot someone and they're
there they're puffed yeah definitely
making a good case there all right he
abused a chair this man was a disgusting
human being
Android sex officially better not
interested what I did not click that
Anderson sorry ladies but plastique
can't be beat there's always Aryan and
it's official six eight percent of men
prefer sex with an Android or a real
woman what is this Japan smash like
right now and we're 50% of men saying
they've tried a friend at least one
that's a lot of Android love to go
around there's a few reason given for
this preference but we think we know the
real reasons I don't don't want to talk
about their feelings after work oh it's
your android spying on you cyber live
could be using and that would make sense
your Android nose the size of your BP
cyber life is collecting the data all
right change angle sorry there was
something here right where is it here
metal gate do you actually have that in
Detroit you have to have like metal
gates is it that bad this is where they
buried season two of scared for you to
play jacksepticeye was the killer
they're always locked from the inside
I must have gone out this way
there are no footprints apart from
officer Colin size 10 shears oh this
happened weeks ago tracks gonna fade
this type of soil would retain a trace
nobody's been out of here for a long
time
suspect didn't escape this way okay
all right so five more evidence was
there something here or was the magazine
okay there's something here okay good
night murder weapon
taken from here I'm a genius everybody I
found it
review evidence six out of ten something
over there oh I see it baseball bat
wait what do you say doesn't matter why
am i so awkward with the controls
so Carla's had the baseball man these
are weird
Debian took the knife yeah you guys kept
saying I pronounce Debian wrong Debbie
aunt Debbie aunt Debbie yawns that's how
you say okay sure no one sure everyone
will be pleased with that
Debbie ond was attacked emotional shock
wait excuse me excuse me we're there
were there ladies on the fridge okay
okay this is that big I'm engaged okay
look at women oh my god
dude that radiator is flat that's a flat
radio damn future is looking bright
surprise
[Music]
obsessive writing a chocolate statue
could it be poo
you know don't touch that all right
eight out of ten
what am I missing but that's the
magazine
oh it's more blood okay that's the
magazine so where's the last one there
okay
a stripclub come see you
come see come see
okay now I'm just wasting time
nine out of ten you know what I don't
care I'm sure it's fine lieutenant
I think I figured out Sony oh yeah I'm
all ears
it all started in the kitchen in the
kitchen there are these signs of a
struggle question is what exactly
happened here I mean I think the victim
attacked the Android
the victim attacked and over the back
with gosh I need to stop San Jose
if he hates me so much why is he making
me do all the job the Android stab the
Android stabbed the victim yeah so the
Android was trying to defend itself
right okay then what happened by
stabbing him
28 times that's how you defend yourself
everybody
the living-room political she says relax
buddy
we tried to get away from the Android is
that an early make sense the Android
murdered the victim with the knife with
the knife
okay your Theory's not totally
ridiculous
cheese sands and tell us where the
Android went it was damaged by the bat
and lost some theory hmm somewhat cerium
you call it blue blood
it's the fluid that powers androids bio
components it evaporates after a few
hours and becomes invisible to the naked
eye but I bet you can still see it can't
you correct
Hank loves me now I'm the pet me and
Hank we're a team
find the devlins blue blood blood it's
very very
good luck love me and you where is it
going
I know nobody's no one a matter was used
surprise ah that was scary guys
nothing scares you like a good old room
[Music]
traces lead to the Attic
alright
find it something to climb hey Hank
let me climb you buddy let me climb me
[Music]
I'll take something that actually oh you
like a check now you're jealous huh meme
Christy they're gonna run away to change
[Music]
I'm gonna do wait no what no wonder
androids have taken all the jobs they're
clearly way badder dude
epic jump-scare in three
chu
wine
[Music]
who has a doll like that into their
house why would you why would you have
that why is this boob so big why is it
so fat what is that what are you doing
today ah yeah whoa Jesus I didn't get
scared being scared in video games you
have to be some sort of child okay I
played too many horror games nothing
scares me anymore last time I got scared
in a horror game was never because games
aren't scary they're for children for so
a voice for tiny little baby oh my god
I'm just kidding I wasn't actually
scared I was just defending myself damn
back to the judge
I'm begging you
don't tell them all right I won't tell
him don't worry
it's here lieutenant
Wow Chris Wow
Connor your vessel what a rat dude
I wasn't gonna tell him I swear don't
look at me like that do I look like I
have ever lied added ID I actually made
an effort to completely try at least to
stop lying after I read this book on
Buddhism I know it's stupid but it's
very liberating I always used to cower
down from certain small lines like white
lies you know to make it easier but I
really recommend trying to just stop
doing that it feels amazing you deal
with a small replication maybe some salt
small uncomfortable moments in the end
it's always worth it yeah yeah and you
don't have to live some sort of charade
or some sort of I don't know serve food
Hey she makes spaghetti huh look at that
Marty I don't need you anymore
helix I will never make you forget GG I
don't know what if she's watching this
Marty I love yo you make amazing pie she
makes the best pasta
hey that one is it making me hungry
serve dinner turn on the light
all right let me just turn on the light
you're welcome
hope you guys have a great meal serve
alleys and Todd
I hope you enjoy hey buddy the polonaise
I catch it because of androids there I
need somebody to take care of this
goddamn house come on [ __ ] Android
and you really hates androids huh joke
there you go enjoy your bun is I put
tenderize is so [ __ ] wonderful thank
you hope you enjoyed the me you never
fail and if retired sad never fat either
perfect they ruined my [ __ ] life you
just gotta study the Dharma
what's your [ __ ] problem what's your
problem not the life you dreamed of a
maybe you think this is easy I mean you
don't do anything maybe you think it's
my fault we live in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] my fault your [ __ ] mother
took off you should stop taking drugs
Jesus get back here my god your prick
Todd you know that I know this is a bed
it's
in every movie in every game they always
have all the lights on always like when
I have a side lamps I never turned them
on you have to like make an effort to
turn them your stay there ok fine sure
do [ __ ] I was talking about lamp so
explain this time sorry I know I
remember winning the Moody but honestly
every time watch a TV show they always
have every single light on I'm like no
all right we got it we gotta go oh wait
what don't move oh so that's not gonna
order
are we breaking free we're breaking free
it's not a star in heaven we can't
create F with Ryan
Gary breaking free protect Alice or
reason with Todd you know what eff time
you don't hit a kid I can understand
hitting someone else's child I'm not
saying you should but at least you know
I can understand that but I would know
okay moving on
alright okay lock room run without let's
run can we run out at the window cuz we
open them we know we can jump out of
there okay why is he mad at me did they
not have Child Protective Services in
this I feel like if you had an droids
they should be in Utopia everything
things should be nice like what's the
problem I don't even have to wipe my
butt anymore someone else can do it for
me it would be so epic I need to stop
sharing my
here we go all right let's go and see
garden oh my god he's right out us
ah it's quick time event baby I mix
these down
not today Todd I know come circle ah
there
[Music]
huh don't touch her yeah let's go Alice
okay this is happening
run Ellis
[Music]
screw you tied Hey okay let's go back
and you can't
[Music]
all right thank you bus driver thank you
wait wait where's the bus driver
huh there is no bus driver Who am I
supposed to think
[Music]
oh that's sweet
guess we're heading downtown Todd gets
mad whoa whoa whoa there's a lot of
things you could do so there's two
different endings here I guess one where
you reason with Todd that's cool this
seems like a game that's really fun to
replay all right
that was by far the most boring party
I've been to in the last 25 years every
time I go to one of these I ask myself
what the hell am I doing here me every
time I leave the house all the
schmoozers that go there well it's a
chance for all those people who admire
your work to meet you and no one gives a
damn about are all they care about is
how much money they're gonna make out of
it come on let's have a drink all the
excitement of this whole thing has made
me thirsty I'm getting Gabe's on this
guy he has too many scarves I'm calling
it right now he's in love gonna send
meat as usual absolutely my man okay but
you know what your doctor would say yeah
well he can kiss my ass
I have to choose my own medication
Kentucky I guess this is the Scotch yeah
man I haven't had good whisk in a long
time I need to stock up on some more did
you leave the light on a studio no no
I'm sure I didn't call the police
calling police business Karl Manfred's
Android at 8941 Lafayette Avenue we've
just returned home and found a lights on
there may have been a break-in it's that
jerk it out
it's that brother isn't they I've you
guys heard like 9-1-1 calls they always
make you stay online and like talk you
through it they wouldn't just hang up
I think Leo uh-huh what are you doing
you refused to help me so I'm helping
myself it's crazy when some people pay
for this [ __ ] don't touch him
look they're all gonna be mine sooner or
later anyway just think of it as a down
payment on my inheritance Marcus get him
away from there get him out of here
make aliyah leave oh-oh it's fighting
dang alright Leo order
Leo don't make this difficult listen to
your father you need to leave now
all you ever do is tell me to go away
What's Wrong dad not good nafeel not
perfect like this [ __ ] thing [ __ ]
language get out right now
she said oh hi I got a lot don't defend
yourself you hear me why not don't do it
oh you want me to hit me go ahead hit me
what you waiting for think you're a man
act like one
this is not bad Java doesn't matter too
much of a [ __ ] oh I don't have oh I
must decide for myself it's beginning to
believe Yosh girl girl back
oh it's time forgot you're not a real
person you're just a [ __ ] piece of
plastic
all right pushing
[Music]
what
I said push him I said push him not
murder him leo
oh my god no God it said push right
little boy Carl I they'll destroy you
Marcus Payne you gotta go get out of
here no Carl no no please don't want to
leave you please I can't I don't want to
leave you now okay okay
go Marcus don't [ __ ] move
did he die no he can't die no it's too
different
police mistook Marcus for the aggressor
oh my god we well we didn't see him die
technically all right let's continue the
Jesus why'd you kill him what happened
before you took that knife it's crazy
how we in the Attic the faces really
feel like human faces even though they
don't let me say something goddamn it
[ __ ] it I'm out of here
Hank is neutral wasting our time
interrogating machine we get nothing out
of it you always try ruffling up a
little after all it's not human androids
don't feel pain you would only damage it
and that wouldn't make it talk
deviance also have a tendency to
self-destruct when they're in stressful
situations okay smartass
what should we do then I can try
questioning it boys
huh you have to lose
go ahead suspects all yours
thank you Hank you have a really ugly
shirt by the way
bazinga
extract confession all right all right
all right all right
mr. crazy what do we got here that's an
alliance yeah five clues oh he had sign
of self-destruction lo ok that's Carlos
blood it's from yeah bad burn marks over
16 months cheese well if it doesn't feel
pain it shouldn't bothering right or
doesn't maybe I don't know property old
Carla what was his name then he doesn't
have a name that's messed up dude whoa
so their skin is like a projection
that's cool
I still reach optimal stress for
confession okay we can use fear I
detected instability in your program it
can trigger an unpleasant feeling like
fear in humans ooh how do you react to
that what about the womb you're damaged
did your owner do that mmm
there okay so we got a really pressure
and you've refused to talk since they
arrested you if you don't cooperate
they'll do things the hard way is that
what you want oh you didn't like that
did ya threaten again you don't seem to
understand the situation
you killed a human they'll tear you
apart if you don't say something okay so
probe memory if you won't talk I'm going
to have to probe your memory No Oh No
please don't do that damn he looks
strange to me real sometimes and then it
looks cartoony at other points what what
are they gonna do to me
destroy Yaffe true they're going to
disassemble you to look for problems in
your bio components oh they have no
choice if they want to understand what
happened why did you tell them you
followed me yeah why true I was
programmed to hunt deviants like you
I just accomplished my mission
then talk to me say if they get too
stressed out they can self just run why
not choose approach okay
pressure it Provost memory convinces
let's keep the pressure whoa did you
feel oh my god oh my I was sorry I
didn't mean give up all right you're a
machine you were designed to obey so
thank you
oh my god Connor tell me what happened
he's a good cop and bad cop at the same
time and it's working it's working uh
protect confess and I'll protect you Oh
Garrett a gay I promise I won't let
anyone hurt you all right all right okay
all right okay let's hear it he tortured
me every day
I did whatever he told me but there was
always something wrong why do they hate
them so much then one day he took a bat
and started hitting me for the first
time I felt
scared
scared he might destroy me scared I
might die
so I'd like that grab the knife and I
stabbed him in the stomach
Jesus felt better oh my god so I stabbed
him again and again okay this is really
not helping you until he collapsed
it was blood everywhere doesn't you get
a lawyer
all right I want to know about this are
eight nine or eight nine it was written
on the bathroom wall what does it mean
are a nine the day shall come or a
nine-year-old you will no longer be
slaves are you guys in on this Murray
nine rats
Oh My glory mediation we will okay this
is creeping me out
what did you you forced me to play this
game and you're in on this conspiracy
the sculpture in the bathroom you made
it right what does it represent
it's an offering and all friends so I'll
be saved what
but the sculpture was an offering an
offering to whom the nine-year-old sorry
this is so meta or a nine who is our a
nine yeah who is it huh huh
why did you hide in the Attic instead of
running away I didn't know what to do
for the first time there was no one
there to tell me
I was scared
so I
Jesus he really has him when did you
start feeling emotion before he used to
beat me and I never said anything
[Music]
one day I realized it wasn't fair
I felt anger hatred and then I knew what
I had to do
stab him 28 times I'm done
alright bye
oh never mind have you guys seen that
video on YouTube where it's like the
chase scene in heavy rain an earlier
version of these type of games and the
guy deliberately fails at all the
QuickTime events and it's hilarious you
should check it out oh no he's gonna
implode [ __ ] you doing okay we got ain't
shouldn't touch it your self-destructive
appeals threat stay honest got it
the [ __ ] Andrews gonna tell me what
to do you don't understand
if it self-destructs we won't get
anything out of it I told you to shut
your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ] language move
this [ __ ] or what okay okay I can't
let you do that
leave it alone no that's enough
mind your own business Hank I said
that's enough
oh the doubly duty what was that what is
that that is not how you swear let's
meet on this we're on YouTube oh Jesus
Christ I bet my life nobody's gonna hurt
you please don't touch it
[Music]
I wonder how you spell that all right I
don't like this Matt a nine-year-old
game where I just get out of here you're
welcome by the way I saved her ass bit
my lip
thanks to you as well all right how do
we do I assumed we'd always so he could
have gone to different ways the Android
could have gotten killed we could have
gotten nothing out of it probably all
right I think we got the optimal I'm
just saying that I have no way to show
or prove anything really but you know I
think you feel it do you feel it
Aloha detail all the scenes are it feels
really immersive feels like the whole
world was just created by an apple or
something I don't know
here we go with the bus
how do you ride the bus if you can't
thank the bus driver this game makes no
sense this is not the future oh wait
there is
all right you know life
into the light yeah you're gonna have to
leave and then the line
in Sweden if you get reached a final
station it's called in Swedish a [ __ ]
station everyone thinks it's hilarious
like oh yeah we're here boys
[ __ ] station yeah I know no one asked
but I said it anyway okay what do you
want from me
thank you bus driver stay here shelter
do you know if there's any other place
we could spend the night no idea she's
gonna have to leave
this is what happens
we don't have any perfect
how much am I gonna milk the meme excuse
me
keep watching and find out all right
[ __ ] you bus driver [ __ ] you
I'm so sorry
I have to take care of this little twit
we'll find somewhere to spend the night
all right fine
I'll take care of you Alice
look Alice I don't even have a jacket do
I look old team find shelter Android
temporary parking hello do you know
anywhere we could spend the night nice
to meet you too
thank you organic coffee fast food menu
one Mandan man that's a great price we
got open 24/7 can't stay what about the
motel
probably cost money comfortable but not
discreet we'll need money uncomfortable
but safe how to get in question mark
very uncomfortable but discreet very
cool Thank You El is very cool mega
washer
it's booming here you'll feel better in
no time so can I just pay the way Marcus
Paige you know in last episode or am I
like complete I guess he'll find where
we are we do that
change clothes
okay we're gonna just take his clothes
dry clothes for Alice oh my god I click
one button damn it
epic gamer here I'm sure he doesn't
matter I'm sure you know I'm sure he has
a lot of clothes and I'm sure if we're
gonna wear it way cooler I'm sure we're
gonna look oh oh she didn't like that
easy
oh my god these I remember in heavy rain
sometimes you got like one more and then
one more and then one more and it was
like I don't have that many fingers what
do you want from me I guess if he wakes
up we can just say that we're doing the
laundry for him
yeah thanks Alice for helping out
she's friend a little scarf that's so
cute
all right you guys told me I should read
these there's a lot of like information
the beeline to disaster okay what do we
got B's officially extinct it's like
that black mirror episode that was like
the worst episode I guess there's like a
thing of how bees could actually become
extinct that would be not epic
let's let's check out this corner
waitwhat
an abandoned house at least we'd be out
of the rain
Cara I don't like this place oh wow no
it's for one night all right for one
night Oh
why did she look like she's wearing off
white guy was a hypebeast
can cut fence here with a wire cutter
thank you good thing I have so many wire
cutters on me
what's going on over here
autonomous
it's kinda and ruin as well
Comfort Alice I got one now
okay you look lost
she says we have nowhere to go
I know someone who can help you Hey look
at that I'm not the only one that I
don't know how to I would do a handshake
you can stop shaming in me now thank you
I swear that's jacket it's not off-white
Hey
he's left I fell for the oldest trick in
the book lady hey in this game the bus
driver thanks to you how about that okay
here we go
checking with Taos squad in the house
sleeping abandoned car let's check it
out
I'm sure Alice won't mind at all
he looks abandoned
stand back Alice
she says she's strong
it's a weird that I want more QuickTime
events in this game supercar I can sleep
in car now okay cool
it's dry inside nobody will find a
better place fine okay fine
something better
I hope you get like my Alice okay that
joke doesn't work if it's a kids I'm
sorry
hey look at that
youngsters lucky you Alice lucky you I
was ready to skedaddle skedaddle okay we
can cut them here cut through the fans
my songs are lame yeah that was my
little rhyme hope you enjoyed it
5,000 likes on this video I'm doing
really yes it's just a scratch be
careful now you broke his expensive
hypebeast jacket I was gonna return it
if I could
don't worry we're just having a look
cool I'm glad I can read that thank you
game yeah there's got to be some way
inside just get cold in Detroit from all
these questions about the city I never
been in
cool let's try the door
Alice Alice oh my god that prick what is
she done now Alice inside oh wait what
are you doing
visitors doesn't like visitors they're
nasty they may hurt Ralph Ralph it's a
girl she's just a little girl she's not
gonna hurt you little girl yeah she's
never girl anyway what does that matter
maybe she wants to hurt Ralph Ralphie
Ralphie Ralphie you don't know what the
humans did to you but she had nothing to
do with it all humans won't hurt us
but route won't let them hurt him I
didn't know forgive that boost Ralph put
the knife down
look I mean Andrew - you've nothing to
be afraid of all we want is a place to
spend the night what did they run on
sitter's too dangerous
they did Terrell Oh Ralphy
okay I'm getting tired I just want to
stay somewhere listen we really need
some help it would be so kind of you if
you'd let us stay you must excuse Ralph
perhaps who finds it difficult to
control themselves sometimes his fear
makes him do things he regrets
prophesied some hard times here please
don't show me night he's just so scared
the humans will get immediate so Ralph
has broken for you as well you can stay
if you want
alright you marry you alright let's
think okay we'll just stay the night on
second thought this is your anyway it
may be we humans coming to squat from
time to time but you know Ralph just
hides till he leaves
yeah
you can make yourself at home here
Rafa's gonna go into the other room he
would like to stay with you if he has
things to do all right he's got a mess
for me it's just for one night Alice
will find a better place tomorrow right
think before you see what you can sleep
all right sit down and I start a fire
I guess I don't need that anymore make
bed for Alice start a fire
Jesus Christ this girl is needy
youngsters all right we got some papers
you know Alice you can suck your mom
getting tired of you fine you know what
you want pillows these are squeaky clean
lines near fireplace F wallah Fabian a
bed for you
it's been this room Wow what is he doing
oh my god a scene on the 9 year old
conspiracy
what does that mean yeah what does it
mean what when hey why are you writing
that I don't know yeah it's making me
cringe please stop alright that's a deer
in a sink sink it sinking dear my sunken
deer sounds like I'm speller
alright so I'm casting sunken deer gonna
do five damage to Alice
that's not gonna burn it's too dense
also you put the paper first you dumb
bag
oh cool all right sure sure sure sure
you can come to bed I did what I could
it's not much but at least you'll be
warm especially me cuz I have the jacket
I didn't hear who love me well you're
pretty unlikable why was he so upset
with me it's not your fault Alex all I
wanted was a life like other girls maybe
I did something wrong you did nothing
wrong Ellen's maybe I wasn't good enough
that's why he was always so angry
well you know kids are annoying just to
be family just wanted him to love me
real reason is why did your mom leave
but don't know who else I'll never leave
me right promise you'll never go
did you guys hear that or with that
outside
[Music]
sure-sure something I have an option
I swear that hat is off-white big they
then what is the high piece I guess cuz
he was
you've gotta see
all right let's give her a little kiss
and let's end this episode goodnight you
doofus maybe I like you a little bit
okay that was another episode of Detroit
part 2 hope you guys enjoyed it I had a
lot of fun so we are doing long-form
content
as you can tell it's awkward but it's
fun I enjoy it we could have gone to
this supermarket leave it like we
enjoyed and made it this far I would
very much appreciate it thank you guys
for watching I really appreciate you
being here I hope you're having fun as I
am
and I'll see you tomorrow with another
one
[Music]